mais on a réussi un magnifique
[Rires]
[Musique]
ces lignes ap ap lindsay
feeling ap new left my tears and roll et
non la
date de
la nouvelle vie du docteur roux ali et
de sa famille ne s'est pas déroulé comme
prévu jusqu'à maintenant au contraire il
souhaite loeffel bykov et bintou
deux adultes et sept enfants entassés
dans deux chambres d'hôtel pendant plus
de deux mois sans savoir ce qui les
attend après avoir passé trois mois de
terreur et d'errance en afghanistan et
au pakistan 1 1 ghz hôtel il y aurait eu
des puces délit il y aurait eu vraiment
de l'insalubrité présent dans les
chambres où les familles afghanes en
fait ont été envoyés est ce qu'on a
trouvé un petit peu scandaleux lorsqu'on
pense que dans le fond on souhaitait que
les familles arriviste au canada dans
des conditions qui sont favorables à
l'installation
la capitaine à la retraite hélène le
seul heures à jouer un rô le central
dans l'organisation du départ du dr wali
et de sa famille d'afghanistan l idée
est au mcee par la piètre qualité des
services offerts par le mandataire des
autorités canadiennes
la nourriture n'a jamais été offertes
dans des quantités suffisantes pour la
famille donc ses parents on a dû
transférer de l'argent à dr wailly pour
qu'ils puissent faire des achats
supplémentaires pour combler les besoins
de sa famille de la formation de musique
communication mr thing
le docteur who ali ajoute que les
personnes responsables de gérer leur
accueil et leur dossier de
réinstallation était souvent
incompétente irascible et parfois même
agressive
le ministre fédéral responsable se dit
lui aussi atterré par cette situation il
promet la tenue d'une enquête
non seulement auprès de l'organisme par
les coaches rôle à toronto mais aussi
chez les autres mandataires à travers le
pays
le docteur who ali et d'autres réfugiés
afghans ont fait parvenir une lettre aux
autorités qui fait état des problèmes
qu'ils rencontrent incluant des épisodes
de discrimination à leur égard des
masques blancs
mais
on se doit d'être transparent on se doit
et que rien dans tout ce processus là
donc c'est important de
206 bon niveau culturel mais d'être
surtout sensible que ces familles
viennent de quitter un pays en guerre
puisqu'on leur offrent à leur arrivée
ici c'est pratiquement un même genre de
traitement si le gouvernement prévoit
effectuer des changements à son système
d'accueil des réfugiés il n'a pas encore
établi d'échéancier pour y arriver
[Musique]